buongiorno a tutti vorrei incominciare
facendo vedere un paio di immagini che
sicuramente tutti
ricordate una relativa a un incidente
che c'è stato nell'inizio nel 2012 nel
nostro mar mediterraneo quando la
concordia ha avuto l'incidente che tutti
conosciamo
e stato veramente un disastro ma che se
vogliamo vedere il bicchiere mezzo pieno
in qualche modo è andata meglio di come
sarebbe potuto andare perché dobbiamo
chiederci che cosa sarebbe successo se
il serbatoio della della concordia si
fosse spaccato e il carburante si fosse
disperso nel mediterraneo
il nostro mare oggi probabilmente non
sarebbe lo stesso e le nostre coste
nostre a me nostri nostri amati lidi
balneari non sarebbero esattamente gli
stessi
spostiamoci un po quella andiamo nel
golfo del messico un paio di anni prima
siamo nel 2010 quando la piattaforma
petrolifera credo più famoso del mondo
di water horizon che all'epoca era
utilizzata dalla british petroleum ha
avuto l'incidente che è stato il
disastro ambientale più importante e più
grande degli stati uniti d'america
in quell'occasione ci sono sacre degli
sversamenti per cento sei giorni
consecutivi e più di 500 mila tonnellate
di petrolio sono state disperse in mare
ci sono stati tentativi immediati di
recupero di quel petrolio che però
purtroppo sette anni dopo scopriamo
essere stati addirittura peggiorativi
rispetto a quelle che potevano essere i
benefici che hanno portato ad esempio
curioso sapere che
gli additivi chimici che sono stati
dispersi con nelle sostanze che sono
state liberate sulla superficie
dell'acqua si sono legate alle
componenti più pesanti della degli oli
di petrolio hanno affossato facendo una
sorta di manto di copertura come se
avessero asfaltato fondale marino
quindi sono finiti sul fondale
ovviamente soffocando e ammazzando tutto
tutto quello che hanno trovato davanti a
loro
senza dimenticare che la stessa
piattaforma che è affondata durante
l'incidente ad oggi sette anni dopo è
ancora lì e quindi ovviamente tanti
rifugi e tante tane di tanti esseri
viventi di tante specie sottomarine
purtroppo sono state distrutte
noi un sistema che abbiamo trovato un
sistema che amo definire completamente
ecologico e a suo modo divertente però
per spiegarvi questo curioso progetto
vorrei partire
facendo un passo indietro e partendo da
quelle che sono un po le tre pietre
miliari di questo progetto e che hanno
permesso questo progetto di di nascere
prima di tutto vorrei parlarvi del
nostro territorio non tanto
nell'accezione turistica del termine ma
per spiegare quanto sia importante
conoscere le nostre radici
quando dobbiamo capire dove vogliamo
andare
il nostro progetto tratta della lana
avete sentito il nome si chiama woods
quindi la parola lana è preponderante è
un progetto di questo genere non poteva
che nascere nella terra che è capitale
della lana nel mondo qui si respira
un'aria di imprenditorialità e che non
saper fare con la lana che non ha eguali
in altri posti gli del nostro pianeta e
credo che la conoscenza profonda di
queste nostre radici e la conoscenza
profonda del nostro territorio di quello
che il territorio ci offre ci abbiano
permesso di vedere un po più
nel nostro progetto il secondo punto che
è stato diciamo importante e da guida al
alla riuscita del progetto è sicuramente
la nostra grande madre natura madre
natura ha dei poteri meravigliosi
impensati se noi riusciamo a guardarla
con gli occhi giusti
vediamo che ci riserva un mondo
veramente ampissimo di suggestioni di
colori di profumi e anche di soluzioni
ha dei problemi
pensate per esempio a serpenti che sono
più tipici delle zone australiane che
hanno di veleni pericolosissimi e
dannosissimi per l'uomo nel corpo
i primi a trovare degli antidoti reali a
un morso di un letale serpente sono
stati gli aborigeni che non si sono
inventati medicine composti chimici
intrugli vari con con qualche cosa di
artificiale ma hanno preso delle piante
e dei fiori gli hanno cotti li hanno
acquistati hanno estratto con qualche
sistema o so assolutamente naturale il
loro contenuto i loro principi attivi e
sono riusciti a guarire da dei morsi che
fino ad allora erano assolutamente
letali e questo questo è per quanto mi
riguarda è magia ed è una magia che
tutti dovremmo dovremmo imparare a
guardare einstein diceva guarda in
profondità nella natura e capirai meglio
ogni cosa e questo è un grandissimo
insegnamento perché la natura ci lascia
la possibilità se esplorata con criterio
e con e con uno sguardo curioso
veramente la possibilità di aprire gli
occhi a nuovi mondi il terzo punto che
ci ha fatto un po da guida in questo
progetto sono i bambini sono belle
immagini da farvi vedere che sicuramente
tutti avrete in mente che quella tra
piccolo principe dove si vedono un
serpente che ha mangiato un elefante e
subito sotto la stessa immagine senza la
vista interna della pancia del serpente
questa immagine
è stata oggetto di studi anche
filosofici e di discussioni di dibattiti
non indifferenti perché mentre lo
sguardo adulto in quell'immagine vede un
cappello quindi un oggetto di uso
quotidiano un oggetto che tutti quanti
conoscono un oggetto visto e rivisto il
bambino con il suo sguardo puro
assolutamente incondizionato dove non
apre quei pregiudizi per concetti e dove
non ha una mente già piena di immagini
riesce a vedere una cosa straordinaria è
chiaramente un elefante mangiato non
serpente questo questo sguardo così
ricco di immaginazione così creativo
così puro da pregiudizi e quello che
dobbiamo conservare tutti quanti ed è
quello che ci ha permesso di procedere e
che ha approcciato è affiancato alla
natura ea quello che sappiamo dai nostri
vicini nostro territorio ha fatto
nascere il progetto
il progetto infatti nasce proprio da un
bambino vi racconto questa breve storia
che è veramente divertente ma che vi fa
capire perché dico questo
la storia nasce da un bambino che
combina una marachella a casa verso
inavvertitamente della nafta in un
laghetto nel prato vicino a casa e da
buon italiano ha paura della mamma la
mamma che è il nostro cardine principale
di tutte le nostre vite come italiani
sarebbe arrivata a casa e l'avrebbe
sgridato con una bella sfuriata se non
avesse risolto il problema quindi preso
dal panico si fionda in casa va a
cercare materiale per riuscire a pulire
questo questo pasticcio passa davanti
alla porta di casa del tuo vicino un
materassaio e all'epoca i materassi si
facevano con la lana si fa dare una
manciata di lana e diceva bene provo
anche con questa cosa la lana sull'acqua
e come per magia la macchia sparisce
si si tranquillizza la mamma arrivano
scopre niente e tutto finisce lì
e la questione passa torniamo al 2010
siamo sempre nel golfo del messico i
telegiornali
gli hanno invaso le nostre case con
delle immagini purtroppo veramente
agghiaccianti di quella di quella
circostanza e quel bambino ormai adulto
si ricorda ei ma io una cosa del genere
in piccolo nel mio laghetto di casa
l'avevo vista ed ero riuscito a
raccogliere quel petrolio per cui
partono le telefonate e si coinvolgono
istituti di ricerca sugli universi tagli
persone che lavorano con con la fibra di
lana profondi conoscitori del tessuto e
delle sue fibre e si mette insieme un
team il team di ur che piano piano è
riuscito a ingegnerizzare il sistema
sfruttando le proprietà intrinseche del
materiale la lana infatti non assorbe
l'acqua perché la proprietà di essere
idrofoba però se è a contatto con delle
sostanze grasse le attira se questa è
una sua proprietà nella sua
caratteristica e succede se voi bagnate
una maglia di lana d'inverno quando vi
schizzate lavando le mani
vedete che rimangono i pallini sulla
sola magliano non si deve la fibra
quindi questo è uno sua è una sua
proprietà sfruttando questa proprietà e
sfruttando il fatto che la fibra di lana
se noi la ingraniamo al microscopio
sembra fatta di piccole scaletti né
queste scaletti né per dei principi
fisici di cui non so non annoiarvi
riescono ad attrarre ad assorbire le
sostanze oleose
quindi abbiamo ingegnerizzato tutta
questa una questo sistema è fatto delle
prove abbiamo costruito un prototipo di
un 20 metri perché chiaramente non
potevamo fare le prove in mare ma se si
verificasse una situazione come quella
del golfo del messico o perché no in un
porto qualsiasi dove magari durante il
rifornimento di carburante c'è
effettivamente una fuoriuscita una
perdita quel petrolio lì purtroppo a
lungo andare con con il continuo
reiterarsi di queste operazioni va ad
inquinare va ad intaccare la flora e la
fauna esistente in quella zona e quindi
poi di conseguenza il pesce che noi
mangiamo diventa diventa contaminato
perciò rischia di diventare meno buono
e a farci vivere meno esperienze quindi
che cosa abbiamo pensato abbiamo pensato
di installare su una nave un kit dove si
prende della lana si prende un
recipiente vuoto permette del petrolio
ci sono dei sistemi che reiterano questo
procedimento in cui la lana si comporta
come una spugna selettiva per cui all
oggetto in mare la immergo nell'acqua e
quando la tiro su o come è come se
avessi una spugna completamente intriso
di petrolio quando io la prendo a bordo
della mia nave las primo quello che
ritengo è nuovamente petrolio perché non
additivi chimici e soltanto stato
assorbito quindi quel petrolio lì è
buono non è contaminato può essere
utilizzato la mia lana posso
riutilizzarla più e più volte in quel
ciclo perchè per la prima dozzina di
volte mantiene la stessa capacità
assorbente che attenzione bene e molto
molto elevata
il rapporto è di uno a dieci circa
quindi un chilo di lana è in grado di
assorbire 10 kg di petrolio quindi che
abbiamo che la possibilità di riutilizzo
dello stesso quantitativo di lana con la
capacità assorbente così alta ci
permette di usare relativamente poco
materiale per recuperare grandissime
quantità di petrolio sversato
immaginiamo di reiterare tutto questo in
un processo e in pochissime ore sarebbe
stato possibile recuperare quelle in
famosi e 500 mila tonnellate che nel
2010 hanno letteralmente devastato il
golfo del messico prima di d
andare oltre vorrei farvelo vedere
perché poi alla fine uno ci crede quando
uno racconta ma non è così semplice come
vederlo
io ho preparato questa della lana della
lana lavata unicamente per motivi
scenografici perché la lana lavare
avrebbe un odore veramente sgradevole
comunque questo è il bello della pecora
l'amato abbiamo una bacinella con
dell'acqua che questa acqua del
rubinetto quindi acqua normalissima
aspetta che esposto indietro così magari
si vede è un barattolino in cui ho messo
un pochino di petrolio quindi c'è del
petrolio all'interno
io faccio cadere qualche goccia è molto
denso le metto poco perché si forma un
occhiello sulla superficie dell'acqua
come quando vi capita di avere dell'olio
ma cucina all'interno di un bicchieri
cade una goccia d'olio all'interno di un
bicchiere poi prendo una quantità di
lana piccola non necessita di chi sa che
quantità perché come vi dicevo prima il
potere assorbente e molto elevato
l'appoggio sulla superficie dell'acqua
la immergo leggermente in modo che
riesca ad assorbire per bene
attendo qualche secondo in modo da
raccogliere per bene e ottengo una
spugna indebita solamente di petrolio
qua c'è solo del petrolio e quelle che
scendono sono gocce trasparenti di acqua
che sono rimaste attaccate ma questo è
solamente il petrolio e l'acqua è pulita
se io ho fatto più occhielli quindi
chiaramente dovrei di passarlo ma se io
avessi intriso completamente questo
questo quantitativo di rana e ora los
premessi otterrei la spugna da poterli
utilizzare nuovamente e il petrolio che
recuperi ray sarebbe assolutamente da
portare alla fine ria o quant'altro la
cosa straordinaria è che non finisce qui
perché io il petrolio che ho utilizzato
e c'è la lana che ho utilizzato e che
ormai si definisce esausta nel senso che
non ha più la capacità assorbente vi
dicevo che
c'è una dozzina i cicli che si possono
reiterare dopo questa dozzina di cicli e
non hanno insomma incomincia a perdere
questo suo potere assorbente fino a
esaurirlo completamente quando questo
potere assorbente si esaurisce la l'anno
questo è utilizzata all'interno
dell'ambito edilizio come isolante
quindi con lo stesso sistema che che si
adoperò oggi oppure come cup
combustibile negli altiforni tecnologici
che sono comunque a basso continuo a
basse emissioni di co2 quindi a basso
tasso di inquinamento ma non c'è non è
finita qui perché questa stessa lana non
deve essere un tipo di lana particolare
è la tosa della pecora
quindi come sicuramente tutti coloro che
lavorano sul territorio con questo tipo
di materiale sanno tutto il bello della
pecora non viene utilizzato in effetti
per scopi tessili perché ci sono delle
parti meno pregiate delle parti più
grossolane e poi ci sono delle pecore
che addirittura producono della lana che
è troppo grezza troppo ruvida e non è
adatta all'uso tessile che tutti quanti
conosciamo né abbigliamento né
arredamento per 4 tanto quella lana oggi
è un annoso problema smaltirla perché va
bene che può essere utilizzata queste si
impieghi di cui si diceva prima ma non
la si fa a bruciare perché sarebbe un
peccato quindi come combustibile non
avrebbe senso
la si può usare come nell'edilizia come
come isolante ma diciamo che dipende
dalle tecnologie dei vari paesi può
essere più o meno diffuso come come uso
i materassi e di lana non si fanno più e
quindi i nostri cari amici pastori della
nostra bellissima sardegna fanno un po
fatica a smaltire questa lana per cui
sarebbe un ulteriore vantaggio un uso
ancora più ecologico utilizziamo quello
che oggi è uno scarto un rifiuto
qualcosa che dobbiamo preoccupare più di
smaltire in qualche maniera perché non
sappiamo cosa farcene diventerebbe un
plus e di aiuto fortemente per
salvaguardare il pianeta per raccogliere
un materiale che ad oggi purtroppo c è
prezioso il petrolio
sappiamo se non riusciamo a muoverci
senza senza il carburante quindi abbiamo
la necessità di utilizzarlo e quindi è
un piccolo ecosistema woods tiger wood
recycle ecosystem perché è un piccolo
ecosistema tutto riciclabile tutto a
impatto zero e per ricollegarci a quello
che dicevo all'inizio è un sistema che
ci fornisce mater natura il petrolio ce
l'ho da madre natura l'acqua ce l'ha
dalla madre natura la lana c'è una madre
natura quindi basta guardare in
profondità nella natura per capire
meglio le cose
ed è così che la tradizione incontra
innovazione perché la tradizione di un
territorio dove si conosce questo tipo
di materiale ha portato all'innovazione
di capire degli scopi e degli utilizzi
nuovi che potrebbero perché non salvare
il mondo grazie
[Applauso]